- buck chuck at Trader Joe's is going to
get inexpensive wine brands could
contain up to five times more arsenic
unknown carcinogen than the amount the
Environmental Protection Agency permits
in drinking water one expert noted the
lower the price of wine on a perlier
basis the higher the amount of arsenic
so arsenic is found naturally in our air
soil and water in large amounts it can
increase the risk of heart disease
cancer respiratory illness and other
health problems alright so this story
actually did scare me because before I
became a huge youtube star and now drink
the $8 bottle yes your wine I drank a
tremendous amount of two-buck Chuck I
mean a lot too much for an adult yeah my
nickname oh it's two buck chuck two buck
chuck I mean so they're arsenic you
shouldn't be drinking arsenic should you
technically no I did not be drinking
arsenic but I find it so refreshing yeah
cleanse the palate yes literally out of
your head yes your tongue falls out
totally should this maybe not surprise
us like if you drink wine having costs
two dollars and actually now I read
something somewhere that said that
Trader Joe's - uh Chuck technically by
the technical definition of what wine is
it doesn't even technically qualify
Hawaiian Punch it's like they're doing
something right and they're well it's
all bull it's the grapes that are
actually not they get the worst grapes
that are thrown away from everything
else inside I love Trader Joe's so I
don't wanna I don't wanna make this all
about them they're awesome but but
here's the bigger news story yes what
people cheap wine is going to kill you
anyway
right for other reasons you mean is
gonna ruin your liver you don't need the
arsenic part it's going to ruin your
liver wine in general or cheap wine
cheap wine because guess what if you're
drinking cheap wine you probably drink a
lot of it yeah and it's you know people
been drinking ripple for a long time and
been dying of you know yes cirrhosis of
the liver so are you seeing a story like
this how do you then even go alright I'm
not gonna drink the to buck chuck right
I'm not gonna do that but is the $6 I
mean there's what everyone says with
minds all the time like there's a $58
bottle at a restaurant is that it gonna
be any better for you if that's the next
step it's gonna be like ranked by health
or through a Brita filter I mean that's
what I do
you buy that generate ass stuff you can
find whether it's Bach whatever it is
bored through a Brita filter maybe they
maybe they could sponsor the show I'm
not sure that's I found people just
really record der to do that yeah if
you're drinking one or two glasses of
wine a night I think you're gonna be ok
it's all about moderation you shouldn't
be drinking a lot of alcohol anyway it's
not good for you people clearly clearly
someone who's also not gonna get their
dog stoned I have to disagree with just
wait yeah everything being equal most of
the drinking that I've done in LA since
I've moved like I see is at your house
so I'm not exactly that just happened
where you mean but your but your but
your drinking decent wine there I'm
guessing that's also true I mean she
gets a lot of Kelly you know wonderful
person as incredible we talked about it
before when we're on the incredible
community type I would call them garden
parties called the Napali parties and
people always bringing gifts so they
bring like nice wine everything like
Brent Francis Ford Coppola none of this
two-buck Chuck yeah but could be okay do
you remember that just recently I guess
it was last year they did a blind taste
test but they had box wine yes like a
$30 bottle yeah people could not pick
the difference yes yeah so it's not
about the taste and to take the arsenic
I think I'd rather take the arsenic out
of the wine it's it's like it's a little
like a contractor doesn't spend the
extra twenty cents of foot to put copper
the better grade of copper in your walls
that lead you know ten years later it
wouldn't cost them that much right so do
we recognize this one of these things
I'm not / / regulation but do we need
like the FDA or somebody like rights you
know you mean like right like they look
at every fruit juice that everyone
drinks they water corn high-fructose
corn syrup and our water certainly so do
we need them to jump in here and start
dealing with the wine people smacks of
wine people around I say you wanna be a
little bit sensitive I think part of the
roadside sterilization of white people
should be a nice glass of too much Jeff
for sure if you want to know about the
roadside sterilization of white people
that was in our white people segment we
did earlier that's nothing right over
here and it's down below also anyway -
buck chuck is it killing you